[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Chicago make some noise let me
hear you guys
that's what we like to hear good to see
everybody I wanted to film my specialist
my very first special which puts a lot
of pressure on you all it's my very
first specialist so I want to do
something cool wanted to do something
unique so I'm like I know I'm gonna film
it in a rock club I love rock and roll
music I love Zeppelin Skynyrd all the
modern bands and I got a comedy club
that was being like the movie demolition
man and I could not be happier and I do
have some good news to report right off
the bat you guys here Applebee's is
bringing back the $1 Long Island iced
tea yes the cheapest DUI in town is back
you want to take a tour your local
prison for bucks look I'm all for
drinking yourself to death like Nicolas
Cage and leaving Las Vegas but it should
cost you more than six dollars to
accomplish that feed how many guys
didn't get drunk at Applebee's get
arrested and then they use their one
phone call in jail to call the
Applebee's I left my credit card can
somebody pick it up that's just scary
but folks look in life there are good
deals and then there are discounts that
are dangerous
you're never gonna walk into a pet store
like hey all snakes $1 have at it but
kids seem to like the ones at rattles so
maybe pick one of those that's a
different level of drunk now Applebee's
drunk like a normal drunk you go out
some of y'all probably normal drunk
right now I'm normal drunk right now you
know you go out you have a few beers
your night you wind up at Denny's
Applebee's drunk you wind up in a
different country
normal drunk you go out you pass out on
your buddy's couch Applebee's drunk you
pass out in the middle of the forest all
your friends are dead
and I like to eat I like to drink which
clearly means I picked the right town to
take my special in right here in Chicago
this is where you do it I've been
training for this thing for a long time
so I've been doing stand-up obviously
but then I also I wanted to physically
prepare myself to look great on camera
and so I've been working out with a
trainer the last three months I was
gaining muscle mass losing body fat two
days in Chicago it's all done right back
to square one I had a nap guys in LA I
had an ad you couldn't see it all the
time and I didn't say abs uh I said one
add of the six it was the one right up
here I haven't like a little window in
my bathroom because who wouldn't want to
look and you get out of the shower at a
certain point and you stare in the
mirror and if the light comes through
and you put the staff over ah right here
and the light shines in you can see the
ab and that's God now
thirty-eight-year-old discipline marquel
has got on a plane at LAX and when that
plane landed at O'Hare deep planning was
a very different person it was no longer
the adult Mark Ellis is the 11 year old
chubby Mark Ellis like I like queso pop
corn nuts on car nuts on cart I'm trying
everything in your city
I cannot say no to pizza I will have all
kinds of pizza I'm not a picky person
when it comes to pizza eating I'll do
anything I'll do delivery I'll do frozen
I will take nine Bagel Bites and form
one giant slice gimmick pizzas ruined me
it doesn't matter what the gimmick is
I'm going to buy it I remember being a
chubby little kid and seeing the first
ad for Pizza Hut stuffed crust Oh as a
fat kid that was like our Beatles on Ed
Sullivan moment
everything changed that night the grass
was greener flowers smell sweeter the
diabetes was more type-a it was a good
day I saw a commercial for a bacon
cheeseburger pizza and like khakhra I
can't even help it my hand just grabs my
phone hey it's me send it you know where
to send it like it's gotten so bad my
friends they won't even let me into a
conversation about pizza because my
friends are passionate they'll be
arguing like New York versus Sicilian I
come walking it you can see that guy can
fold all those boxes you guys know if
you order Papa John's and Domino's at
the same exact time the drivers have to
joust it's in the Bible and the Quran it
works both ways it's true the drivers
have to joust and the loser works at
Little Caesars for the rest of his
career
but I'm here in Chicago and I like to do
as the locals do wherever I am so like
if I'm in Kansas City I'm gonna eat some
ribs if I'm in Nashville I'm gonna
listen to some country music oh I'm in
Chicago I'm gonna pay two guys to beat
the [ __ ] out of me
cuz that's what you do justly small it's
an actor not a very convincing one he's
an actor who allegedly allegedly hired
two guys to jump him and it's like dude
why would you hire two people to jump
you're in Chicago if nobody's mugging
you wait ten minutes they're on rounds
and I get it he just wanted attention
he just wanted sympathy and we all want
that he wanted to get a better job I've
had jobs that are so bad I would
actually take the beating over the job
you ever have those sound like you walk
in and you're thinking it's like Tuesday
morning you're just going over all that
stack of papers on your desk and right
before you get to the front door you're
like I just wish someone would come and
pistol with me right now just do it I
don't to be filing reports I'm gonna be
laying in bed collecting cards
I went get well cards not get well soon
cards get well cards cuz I intend to
take my sweet-ass time healing from
these injuries and if that joke offends
you do you guys want to at me you want
to you want to complain you don't have
to worry about it karma already took
care of the job because not a week had
gone by when I was doing that joke what
happened my face got attacked I had my
own face when you can still probably see
it right here so I got mine done for
free here's what
here's what happened I'm the co-owner of
a dog she's a half eagle half Boston
Terrier named Maui she is fantastic she
is the best she just lets me borrow her
Instagram handle once in a while so the
way that I come by Molly is that she
belongs to my ex-girlfriend now my
ex-girlfriend I are still really good
friends and Molly and I are still best
pals so that makes me the dog stepfather
I get to be the stepfather
of this beautiful dog and being a dog
stepdad is a lot like being a kid
stepdad it's the same thing you come in
there already done with potty training
so the only the only rule you have to
adhere to is as soon as you're done
having sex with a mom you give them a
treat and all is good so and so Molly no
we go to the dog park all the time and
it's great now Molly was not in this
particular freitas Molly as soon as she
goes to the dog park she doesn't really
want to talk to other dogs she's done
sniffing buds she just wants to go
around the perimeter
like she walks around the outer
perimeter of the dog park like she's Tim
Robbins and Shawshank like casing the
joint for some sort of weakness and
these two big dogs started getting that
and I saw it and I'm like you know what
I can break this up with my hands let's
see how my face does and I got right in
there and a dog chomp took a chunk out
of my face and it really hurt and it's
such a sad realization knowing you are
not gonna be on Tiger Beat this
particular month it's rough math but the
scariest part about being bit by a giant
dog it's not the pain it's not the
aftermath when you're bleeding the
scariest part about being bit by a giant
canine is the next night it was a full
moon
yeah that's not cool like I've seen a
lot of movies and I'm driving home and
the clouds part and I see the moon and
I'm like wait a my itchy cuz allergies
or something else going on here yo I
raced home I run into my apartment now I
don't own any silver bullets but I drink
a lot of Coors Light so fun in sugar six
pack I blasts Bob Seger and the Silver
Bullet Band and I healed myself of my
werewolf tendencies and that's what you
got to do man you got to take the law
into your own hands there because you do
not want to become a werewolf you become
a werewolf what's gonna happen is you go
crazy you know Harry you run around you
attack people you kill some people you
wake up in the woods the next that you
lean over there's a guy there dude what
do you do I don't know man I went to
Applebee's last night and this happened
I love traveling I travel around a lot
people make the misconception about
comics that were on tour and sometimes
will brag about it like hey I'm going
out on tour comics don't really ever
tour rock stars hip hop artists they go
on tour comics weirdoes in Jacksonville
like our tours don't have cool names
this isn't the Mark Ellis invasion tour
this is the let's see if Mark pays his
rent again this month tour I was pay my
rent a couple months ago I was in
Indiana doing a college because success
and I was doing a Paraiso college and I
get in there and I stayed at a hotel
I've never had the walls this thin in my
entire life and I'm saying I'm not gonna
name the hotel but let's say if you were
going on a holiday this is the end you
want to avoid staying there and I can
hear people having sex above me I can
hear people having sex below me I can
feel people having sex right next to me
yes sir old Mark Ellis was trapped in an
Indiana [ __ ] you
[Applause]
and then I got to go do a show the next
day I got to do a college show and the
kids are great they were awesome it was
like 300 kids there so afterwards we
were doing the meet-and-greet I'm taking
pictures with the eight of them that
stuck around and they all came up they
all asked me the same question they said
hey are you gonna go to the Chocolate
Factory and I'm like I what is the
Chocolate Factory I think I might have
heard some people going to the Chocolate
Factory last night some colloquial
Midwestern thing like guy yeah here he's
taking her to the Jacqueline factory
tonight but no apparently outside Valpo
there's like one of the more recognized
chocolate factories in the United States
which is cool except I am way too old to
want to go to a chocolate factory
because I'm an adult on these college
kids they're wide-eyed they're excited
they haven't seen Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory like I have seen Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory is when
you're a little kid you watch that movie
you think wow look at how much fun a
chocolate factory would be as an adult
you watch that movie and you realize
none of those kids made it out of that
factory alive the only one that escaped
with his life was Charlie Bucket and he
got the worst deal out of any Oh Charlie
and Willy and Grandpa Joe take off in an
elevator that has never been tested
before and Whitley offers him in an
elevator so it's not like Charlie can
say no Willie says you know what Charlie
you get the keys to the factory it's
yours
because what 13 year old wouldn't want a
factory job for the rest of his life
wall goes one in that place like the
fire festival here's the keys I am gone
I have fun with the investigation I'm
going to Aruba so I did not go to the
Chocolate Factory I went to a nearby bar
and I had myself some fizzy lifting
drinks and I got nice and I got drunk
and then I realized hey mark you're
drunk you know it's time to do now send
an uber your way back to your hotel so I
walk outside pull up over and I realize
it uber is a very different experience
in Indiana because LM in Chicago I live
in Los Angeles you pull up you're over
here and there's cars all around and one
of them is gonna pick you up and take
you home
right Indiana very different experience
because uber in Indiana that app it's
just a map Randy is not away so you're
walking home and it really it's one of
those moments of clarity you have
because you realize how much you rely on
technology to take care of yourself like
uber I trust that way too much when you
break it down it's just an app on your
phone you hit a button and some stranger
in a Kia shows up and we trust that
person to give us a ride home it's like
well you knew my first name I guess I'll
show you where I sleep come on this way
babe a new service that is introduced
and this is only in Southern California
right now and it's called sober scooter
get ready to get creeped out listen to
this so let's say you're out drinking
right you don't want to drive your car
home so you call sober scooter that
means somewhere else in town there's a
gaggle of dudes and they all have a
scooter one of them gets a call hops on
their scooter and rides their trusty
steed to the bar where you are you give
them your car keys you walk out to your
car they put you in the passenger side
pop the trunk put their scooter in your
trunk again the driver's side drive your
drunk ass back to your own house in your
own vehicle yeah and if you think that's
a good idea
you've never been stabbed
it's like if I tip him does he come in
and read me a bedtime story you know
afterwards he gets his scooter back and
he goes home to Grandma's basement to
put on the skin or whatever Cline he had
last week that's an adult that rides a
scooter which means by definition he
sucks at driving a car
Society has deemed him worthy of two
wheels and a helmet that's it
I'm not letting Jerry near my car he's
not getting near the Ford Fusion I'll
tell you that much you heard me right
ladies
Ford Fusion yeah sounds futuristic
because I'm not getting laid in the
future either I've had three cars in my
life I had I had a 95 Honda Civic you
know good starter car the X Wing of
Earth
and then I upgrade it to a Chrysler 300m
which had one previous owner and her
first name started with M and ended with
um and then jr. finally stepped up said
you know I'm gonna get my car I'm gonna
go lease a Ford Fusion and so I put on a
watch and a collared shirt so the guy
thinks I'm employed and I show up wise
were told to credit reports fabricated I
got the lease walk out to the car first
thing you should see in the new car he
doesn't show me any of the cool stuff
inside because inside the car it's
amazing you can name your car whatever
you want and your car will respond to
the name you give it I drive around and
I tell Commissioner Gordon to play hot
for teacher and he'll do it problem is
he didn't show me that first thing he
does is he takes me around back he pops
the truck and he's like dude check this
out inside the trunk there's a handle
you can pull in case you get locked in
your trunk get on in there man try it
out plenty room for you and your scooter
you're gonna have a good time in that
trunk and I bought the Ford Fusion I
like the car fine but there's a lot of
pressure because I'm originally from the
south and anytime you're from the south
you're gonna have redneck friends who I
love but redneck friends they always
make you buy American doesn't matter
what you're buying it could be gum
refrigerator Indian food that [ __ ]
better be made right here I told my boys
back home I'm getting a new car that's
when they perk up there we go you're
gonna buy American right and if you
bought like three more of them come out
of the bushes you say American already
is he gonna buy American so I did I went
out there I bought a Ford Fusion okay
that's a car made right here in the
United States of America by legal aliens
using foreign parts it was made right
here
and I feel like I can claim the south I
was born in North Carolina grew up
mainly in Virginia which it it's like
the good south we'd like fireworks we
can read it's a good mix of the two
and when I say read you guys know I mean
watch vids on YouTube it's the same
thing but now our family's all spread
out because I live in California my mom
my sister they're back in Virginia my
brother's up in Seattle so we're all
spread out which is great for me because
in my family my role simple I got the
best job I am an uncle I'm an uncle and
being an uncle is easy because being an
uncle means you come to town once a year
and you get to be cool you get to be
that uncle you blow into town you bring
them some presents you tell some funny
stories you get out of Dodge they think
you are awesome remember you're a kid
I'll cool you thought your uncle was you
didn't know that Uncle Bob lived on a
houseboat didn't pay his taxes you know
idea I loved being an uncle being an
uncle is like if Guy Fieri was a person
like that's how cool it is I'm not
making fun of Guy Fieri because trust me
uncles that's like our l ron hubbard we
love that guy Guy Fieri is the ultimate
uncle because he knows with every uncle
dreams up every time you see Guy Fieri
on TV what's he doing he comes into town
he's driving some badass sports car
cranking 80s rock the locals like hey
guy he tells some funny stories he cooks
for him next morning guy gets the hell
out of town and the locals like come
back soon guy that's what uncle's won
you don't visit us you do not come visit
the uncles uncles we come to you you
cannot visit guide because flavortown is
not a place it's a state of mind
some great things that happen once you
become an uncle for instance did you
guys know once you become an uncle you
never have to buy flip flops again
they're automatically there every room
it's like magic it's like the ten now in
Santa Claus movie okay to become an
uncle I had to push another one off the
roof and now every morning I wake up
whether I like it or not I got gas
station sunglasses crow keys and a
federal boobie inspector shirt I found
out I was gonna be an uncle because four
years ago four years ago I got a text
message from my brother and all it said
was hey Kate's pregnant
and so I did what any good older brother
should do I wrote him back is it yours
yeah you gotta make sure no I didn't
realize her whole family is also cc'd on
the text message
there's certain things that these
sunglasses emoji does not cover of it
but that's how my family communicates
that it's all done by text chain it's
all the same three things it's either
recipes gardening tips or pictures of
the kids and I love seeing pics of the
kids but if you're a parent out here I
have a memo for you from the rest of us
we don't need to see the bathtub once I
know every kid you see there in the
bathtub and it's soaked you keep that
[ __ ] to yourself okay to you it's
adorable to me it's a felony I don't
want it on my phone all right I want to
see a picture of the kid oh not have
myself on a federal watch lists okay if
you're a parent you upload that to
Instagram it's 20 likes if I upload it
it's 20 years no thank you
don't need that stuff in my life and I
know being a parent stuff I know being a
parent there's so much responsibility
you have to close it you have to feed it
you have to hug it and so we probably
stopped calling it after some point and
it's life and I don't want to go through
any of that and I think it's tougher
today there's some things that have made
parenting easier like medicine
Blue's Clues there's some ways that it's
cooler but it's tougher now to
discipline your kids because you can't
do what used to be able to do to
discipline kids try to spank your kid
today see what happens you try to spank
a kid today they're gonna tell on you
yeah they're gonna find a neighbour a
teacher a news crew they're gonna rat
your ass out back when I was a kid the
spanking was in play the spank was a
possibility now the story goes in my
family that there's three kids an older
sister younger brother and me the middle
one only one of us ever got spanked and
it only happened one time and it's from
the guy it's talking to you right now
what happened was that I got spanked and
my dad apparently felt so bad about the
spanking he could never lay a hand on
any one of us ever again yeah we didn't
know that
so the threat was still there all you
have to do is like this rolling all
right well and if we didn't shut up then
all my dad did he grabbed his belt
buckle I were like what is happening now
that's is he taking his pants off this
has got creepy dude what got even more
we on the road trip remember the road
trip with your family discipline at 80
miles an hour on the highway I was an
Air Force brat so you move around all
the time every road trip same situation
dad drives mom's in the pasture seat
three kids in the back now as soon as
the road trip began mom passes out so he
about spending time with us made her
sleepy so she's done so now dad's got to
do everything right he's got to do all
the driving the navigating and the
parenting this is back before the GPS
day so he had like a map folded like
over here cranking an Arby's beef and
cheddar in this hand and he's trying to
drive so if we got loud the backseat
first thing my dad did never yelled at
us right away first thing my dad did is
he got really quiet focused like he's
planning what he's gonna tell the cops
after this bloodbath ensues louder
that's when it got physical that's when
you'd see dad driving with this hand and
then this hand comes off the wheel
this hand grabs the wheel so this one is
free to just hit whatever he can find in
the backseat my dad always had a bad
rotator cuff and now I know why it's
like this
and that was always cool with me and my
older sister because we always made my
little brother ride [ __ ] Suzette Han
came up were like get in there Robbie
learnt some life lessons that was the
only time my sister and I ever really
teamed up as kids we're cool now we love
each other but back then we were at odds
most of the time except for the road
trip that was the only time we colluded
together it was like two sovereign
nations teaming up to get a common enemy
like if Japan and China team up to get
North Korea or at the United States and
Russia team up to get the American
people it's like that but if that didn't
shut us up my dad would shift to Phase
three now phase three this is the all
time to add threat on the road trip
that's where he would say if you kids
don't shut up right now
I'm gonna pull this car over the side of
the road and just to reinforce it he
pull over to the grate a little bit
everybody go he's doing it he's doing it
said I'll pull this car over yank you
out line you up on the side spank each
one of you in broad daylight and if you
saw that happen today somebody else on
the road is gonna call child services
but back when I was a kid other cars
would see that and start honking their
horns
brap brap use your belt it's more fun
the police will be driving behind I dude
that's awesome you wanna borrow my
nightstick some pepper spray you got
sober scooter comes by can i play with
those kids after you're done
I love my dad though man I consider I
consider my dad to be my all-time best
friend my dad passed away a few years
ago around this time but he he's my
all-time hero he's my best friend I know
that he's up there watching over me
everything I do except like shower
cuz that'd be be a little creepy right I
think I know how it works but I'm pretty
sure when I go to the bathroom he goes
outside and plays catch with John Lennon
I'm really spitballing ideas hopes
really my dad always had this
catchphrase that he'd see you would
always say proud of you boy if I did
something good he'd have to use it much
but when he did yeah you got a good
grade on a test or I had a good
basketball game you say I'm proud of you
boy proud of you boy and I've always
tried to make him proud so one of the
things I loved doing as a comic he gives
me the great privilege to entertain our
troops I just got back from a USO tour
overseas and I was in Jordan you go in
your Syria near Iraq and it's amazing
it's eye-opening to be over there
because this is the military like
they're willing to go overseas and
defend our freedom me I will fake being
sick to get out of playing paintball
well once you get over there
you do the show for the truth they love
it and then they take you around there
we go let's show you what we do for a
living and I'm all about it like I got
to put on the suit from The Hurt Locker
which is like such a shitty way to say
it because it's not from the movies like
we went to the Smithsonian I'm like
that's the one these are real things
these are things that people do they get
me in the suit and the suit weighs like
a hundred pounds you put on the helmets
like another thirty pounds and I hooked
to him after I have it on I'm like all
right let's do some push-ups boys and I
get down there so two hours later they
revived me and we move on to the night
the next station I love the next station
because that's where all the German
Shepherds are that will go after
suspects they'll like you snap your
fingers they go to run and charge them
and usually I volunteer to put myself in
the big rubber suit don't think that's
gonna happen again
and then this trip I got to do something
I've never gotten to do before and I was
so thrilled I got to meet a pilot got to
meet a pilot and you think well mark you
don't meet pilots when you go do shows
no the pilots are off somewhere else
they never come to the comedy shows
because they're studying or their
training or they're playing volleyball
they are doing something important but
they take me up to the tarmac and
apparently this pilot is a fan of mine
and so I see an f-18 LAN I didn't even
know the FS went that high it lands and
it pulls in to its parking spot I don't
know both in and then I started to get
real intimidated because the cockpit
opens and emerging is this 7-foot tall
stallion he was like five five but to me
he's like seven feet took his helmet off
he had short hair but I just saw flowing
locks like for the grass Kerr this is a
normal day for me I'm looking at a Fabio
book cover the guy gets gets off the
plane he climbs down the ladder and he's
walking towards me he's got the cool
aviator shades and he's got that
confident you know I just flew a [ __ ]
airplane walk and I get ready to shake
his hand and one of the grounds crew
leans him - hey hey his call sign is
molar I'm like oh I was expecting a
maverick and Iceman molar and then they
say yeah they call him molar because the
last time he was in a bar fight he
knocked the guy's teeth out
and keep mine this is like right before
I'm like up here to meet molar and mower
comes in any grat he has that like alpha
handshake where he just takes you
straight down you know he's like hey how
you doing oh my god oh god that's it and
I didn't know what I was gonna say to
him because I'm excited to meet it but
then I hear this mower thing only did he
fail out of dental school wait what's
the inside this is what this is the
first words out of my mouth he comes up
he's like hey I'm Mahler and I went
flossing and flying
[Applause]
[Music]
Moeller felt sorry for me
puts his arm over my shoulders like a
man let me show you around the flange so
he shows them around the f-18 and I love
everything I'm saying but then I get
transfixed on one particular part I'm
right here I'm looking up at a missile
or if you're from Britain it's called a
misael I'm looking right up there and
and Moeller can see that I'm enamoured
with or as he would say enameled with
this missile I'm looking at it and so
Moeller says hey let's get this guy a
stepladder and he's gonna autograph the
missile and I'm like yeah I'm gonna
audio do I go to hell for that if I so
they bring a stepladder and more he just
pulls a sharpie out of one of his many
pockets I know if y'all know this the
military loves pockets you seen those
uniforms their code is like God country
pockets family so sharp yeah he's like
here you go man autograph it and so I'm
thinking like Oh God all these people
are gathered around waiting to see what
the funny boys gonna write on the
missile and I'm like oh god what do I do
so I get up there flossing and flying
[Applause]
that's my big opener and then I I signed
my name I drew some shark teeth up at
the van Halen logo on it and then I
wrote four out of five dentists
recommend dismissal and I should have
dropped the mic there but I kept going
the last thing I actually wrote on there
was I put my Twitter handle on it what
kind of a douche puts a Twitter handle
on a missile like I'm thinking if this
thing's a dud I'm gonna get some new
flowers out of it just get a tweet in
the middle of the night lol better luck
next time
some good news in the world - this
happened a couple weeks ago there's a 98
year old woman that just graduated from
college
98 somebody turned 90 Ford was like I
gotta get my life together where are you
going on spring break heaven College is
supposed to be the best four years of
your life not the last four years of
your life just thinking about when
you're that old you don't have to go to
class right when you're here 90s you
already live like a college kid you've
the same schedule you get up you get
high you watch The Price is Right back
to bed that's it clock out Mildred your
day is complete that's the greatest
generation for you she's under 90s and
still being productive I'm 38 cannot
wait to get into a retirement home you
seen those ads on TV I saw an ad phone
the other day I live in Los Angeles this
place is in Florida their advertising
3,000 miles away because they know they
can hook this guy comes on late at night
and I'm watching I see this ad for this
retirement home I want everything I'm
looking at I want the bingo the pudding
the bedpan I want it all end of the ad
is the best part the end of the ad it
says the villages and then their tagline
free golf for the rest of your life I'm
like that's awesome and five minutes
later I'm like it's a little cryptic -
it
is that a great deal or they just
betting the pop up ain't gonna make it
all 18 holes get up to the start II like
what's the back nine look like no one's
ever made it that far we don't know I
did go to college I did the college
thing I I majored in communications it
was a total waste of Lori Loughlin money
I don't because I think when you go to
college you go with one to two mindsets
you didn't go to college with a goal you
go to college with an idea well you go
to college with a goal your way I'm
gonna be an accountant I'm gonna be a
lawyer that's probably gonna come true
for you go to college with an idea I was
like that maybe I'll be a doctor that
doesn't work out I got comedy Hey
so I take biology I take the intro to
biology and this is my very first
semester I'm not gonna tell you guys
what I got on my first test like I don't
even remember but my second test comes
back from a scale of 0 to 100 and all it
says on it says 53 that dot dot nice
improvement I saw that I'm like I better
be hilarious because and it's so funny
that I get to like perform at colleges
now and like kids listen to me
they asked me serious questions after
the show what can ask me what what
should he major and I'm like I don't
know do it especially now do what makes
you happy dude have you seen the state
of the world we could be gone tomorrow
like it used to be they go well what's
the future gonna hold I don't know we
have a future guys we're having a good
time in here it could be the Book of Eli
out there right now okay
biggest misconception that people have
about comedians is that we love when a
president like Donald Trump takes office
because we get so much material and
that's true we get a lot of material but
the problem is he's giving us a little
too much like every day the guy invents
a new way to be a [ __ ]
he's like the Thomas Edison of stupid he
just keeps developing new things like
he's hung up on the past that last week
he was giving Obama [ __ ] about his birth
certificate again so no we never saw his
birth certificate does anybody know
where their birth certificate is come on
man does anybody have it framed above
their fireplace that was me live birth
that was me I get this okay if you voted
for Trump in this room
I don't automatically think you're a
racist or a sexist okay
I like your odds don't automatically
think that because I'll admit Hillary
Clinton had shady [ __ ] going on to
Hillary Clinton deleted 30,000 emails
and I know she did it on purpose
because my mom's the same age as her and
she's never deleted one email in her
entire life we get hung up on the small
stuff too
like social media makes everything worse
they know I hate Trump and so fans say
oh can you believe you did this you
believe you did that at that McDonald's
thing Clemson Tigers the national
championship football team got invited
to the White House to have dinner
shockingly they accepted and they show
up and everybody's like can you believe
Trump served in McDonald's if Obama done
that we'd all be like ATS guy gets it
yeah he's this guy knows what the young
people are into and I'll be honest if
I'm having dinner with Trump I want it
to be fast food because I want that meal
to go by as quickly as possible we don't
have time to waste on the small stuff
there's big issues right now in our
country gun control that's a huge issue
and I travel all over this way I've been
to every state I see both sides of the
argument okay I was in Michigan a few
months ago and Michigan they love guns
now to some people in Michigan they hate
guns there's other people in Michigan
that literally cannot climax unless
they're looking at the Second Amendment
and the Second Amendment says we have
the right to bear arms it also says we
have the right to form a militia if the
government gets squirrely if you guys
have noticed comforts a little squirrely
and if you're honest with yourself you
say okay well if I need a militia to
protect me I probably want the Michigan
one that's like the good one to be on
their team like I want the militia that
likes Ted Nugent Robocop now we have a
militia in California it's just two guys
at Whole Foods with a bow and arrow
that's all we got and I don't like guns
I wish we could ban guns I just don't
think it's realistic you can't ban guns
you're never gonna ban guns it's a noble
cause because people want to stop school
shootings so ban guns not gonna work do
you really want to stop school shootings
don't ban guns ban school it's 2019 we
don't need school anymore I'm sorry but
we don't it's all on your phone I
promise you every question every answer
it's on your phone I think it's gonna
make better adults because if you feel
ostracized at school you eliminate that
if you're a bully at school you get rid
of that false sense of empowerment 90%
of the stuff I learned in school I don't
use the day and that number would be
higher except I never learned how to do
percentages
I went to Catholic school anybody go to
Catholic school yeah some of you guys I
don't know how they did it at other
schools but they never acknowledged sex
or drugs or alcohol that like they were
even like a thing except for one day I
was in seventh grade and your parents
have to sign a permission slip and
that's today it's a 45-minute period
when they're gonna teach you about sex
and drugs they're gonna get it all done
and never mention it again it was the
funniest 45 minutes I've ever
experienced in my entire life because
it's taught by nuns so it's like we're
all walking into the sex talk a little
blind you know nuns don't have sex
because they say they're married to God
and old God ain't putting out so they
kicked off with sex and the sex jihad it
was you have not laughed until you've
seen a nun put a condom on a banana and
then they moved on to drugs and drugs
was great and they're teaching us about
pot they said kids don't smoke pot why
not what's pot it's a gateway drug right
it's a gateway drug it leads to other
things like what snacks [ __ ] free
guitar lessons
sure something I'll probably get high
right to get high sir
[Music]
this is so great because like I was
clearly not looking at you but you felt
the nerves of your friend you were
excited to admit your friend look at me
like I'm an undercover cop like this
would be the best thing operation of all
time I wasn't even a comedian I just
practice stand-up for ten years to get
this [ __ ] right here this is all
alive guys I was at home having dinner
with my wife and kids and I got the call
from the sergeant he's there tonight
all right fine honey I gotta go this
could be the night what's on stage doing
my thing hey who does drugs here you get
the [ __ ] down I'm a comic I don't do it
which is weird right looky comedian what
the hell do I have to do a comic that
doesn't smoke weed that's like living in
Wisconsin and being lactose intolerant
cuz I believe what they taught us it's a
lot safer than drinking when you break
it down it's a lot say like if you go
home done you get high what's the worst
thing it's gonna happen
get stoned you watch Animal Planet you
learn some [ __ ] about turtles but if you
go home down you're drunk you watch
Animal Planet you better look out cuz
some crazy things are about to happen
cuz you wake up the next day you've no
idea what went down all of a sudden get
an email from Expedia confirming your
trip to the Galapagos Islands you don't
learn anything about turtles there might
be Turtles in your place there's Turtles
over here there's bandanas over here and
you're like I was gonna make Ninja
Turtles last night holy [ __ ] and who's
scooter is this how [ __ ] up did we get
last night
I trust ya I can tell you guys this
story I got high once in my life I got
high one time I got high I had a pot
cookie anybody yeah first bite of a pot
cookie does not taste like a cookie but
former fat kid I know that if at first
it doesn't taste like a cookie keep
investigating and as always as soon as
you're done eating the cookie that's
when whoever made it starts freaking out
they're like oh [ __ ] you ate that whole
thing by yourself and I'm like I had
three by myself what's the issue I got
so high that night I wrote a term paper
on why sharks and dolphins are the
Israelis and Palestinians of the ocean
I'd already been out of college for five
years just really stoned on a Tuesday
wake people need to know this this is
important I say do it if pots your thing
if alcohol is your thing don't abuse it
but you know get out of your head space
a little bit it's great what I usually
do for that I watch movies I love
watching movies I'm a big movie fan I
like talking about movies online and I
like getting responses because ten
percent of the time they're positive
sixty percent of the time it's negative
and thirty percent of the time it's just
some gift that I understand so and I
love every category movie every genre I
love watching every kind of movie except
I don't watch action movies
I don't watch them I study action movies
I take notes for when this shit's gonna
happen to me every action movie I think
could happen to make like diehard
diehards the best one for a reason
because we're all watching die hard at
home and we see a guy running around
stopping crime with no shoes on and we
looked at really
I'm making fists with my toes right now
this is uncanny every action movie I
think could be me I saw the first taken
and I wanted someone I know to get
kidnapped sometime get dangerous because
like I can go see a fast and furious
movie in the theatre I should not be
allowed to because I take it too
seriously I see all those car chases
happen on a giant screen for two hours
and then I immediately have to operate a
motor vehicle I get it and I think I'm
in the movie I'm like racing people at
the light doing that hardcore shift you
never have to shift this far unless your
car is made by John Deere you never have
to [ __ ] this hard and I drive an
automatic I'm just going from d2l but I
have to say of all the movies I've ever
seen of all the movies I've ever loved
my favorite film franchise of all time
Star Wars the best Star Wars is the best
I can take so many lessons from the
galaxy far far away and apply them to my
own life I gain endless inspiration from
those movies they teach us so many
valuable lessons one of which is not the
value of a human life
you go back to 1977 the very first one
Episode four a new hope they blow up a
planet to show the might of the Empire
they blow up an entire planet seven
billion people die 30 minutes later
we're having a medal ceremony
did you have to kill an entire the
people George was anybody halfway
through Star Wars you like I'm not sure
who I'm rooting for you
this is and then force awakens was even
worse because force awakens it'll blow
up one planet they blew up five thirty
five billion people died 20 minutes
later we're laughing cuz the Wookiees
cold what was the meeting like with JJ
and not the other writing savvy slight
okay okay we got it we got to take this
up a notch
ideas and one guys like how about we
blow up three planets and JJ's like no
some other guys like JJ I think I have a
way for us to blow up five planets
thirty-five billion people and JJ's like
can we put a lens flare in that
[Applause]
my most controversial Star Wars opinion
as some other people here may have as
well is that the best Star Wars movie
people debated endlessly some people of
the classic trilogy some people loved
the prequels other people get really
high on meth and love the holiday
special but I am proud to say and I'm
saying on camera right now my favorite
Star Wars movie of all time
Return of the Jedi this one you're
saying no sir because you're high on
drugs what's your what's your favorite
source movie Empire Strikes Back I hear
that a lot
hear that a lot and you're gonna throw
your terms at me like oh it's cinema
story acting but my counter-argument is
very simple returned the chat is the
best movie why because in two words we
won we won we did think that we were
trying to do for three but-- we we did
it we blew the thing up again
and this time we didn't have to kill
seven billion people we lost a few
pilots in an Ewok but that's all that
happened that's what I want I don't want
to go through the struggle I just want
the victory if you look at it in terms
of an NFL team Return of the Jedi that's
when we won the Super Bowl the Empire
Strikes Back that's week 11 when we lost
to the Bengals Return of the Jedi I won
I want the good team to win I want the
bad team to lose I would have blow up
the Death Star
I want to drum on stormtrooper helmets I
want force ghost getting drunk with
wedge I want Lando getting a little too
close to Princess Leia I want you back
up hooking up with two Ewoks and nine
months later they have kids and their
names are young and nub that's what I
want so I'm single
I love that I said I'm singing on
something with a crop put their hands up
like we're riding a really depressing
slow ride I'm happy being single
I like being sick I love waking up every
day being like am I gonna shower
probably not I went swimming a few days
ago so I'm good for the weekend and I
broke up and your friends always act
like they care when you break up but
they really just want to know the dirt
your friends get so nosy oh that's the
same question as soon as they hear you
broke up doing oh man are you okay who
broke up with who where around applause
how many people think I broke up with
her
[Laughter]
where we are in that one penalty box you
couldn't show it up I love this crowd
for that reason because y'all are like
look I'll pay money to see this guy but
I'm not sacrificing my integrity by
clapping at a moment that I don't feel
is just he's got his lecture that's
about a walk so we're expected to
believe he broke up with her well I'll
have everyone in this room know I didn't
break up with her chambray go with me it
was a mutual decision both her and her
vibrator agreed it was time I think we I
think we moved in too quickly because
you always think it's gonna be perfect
like both your releases are gonna be up
at the same exact time you're skipping
out you meet on the street hey let's go
find a place together it's not it my
lease had just started hers just ended
so she moved in with me but she never
really declared she was moving in she
just kind of Trojan horse all her [ __ ]
into my place
and it's a guy you don't know what's
happening you're just like man I'm
getting laid a lot this is she woke him
up one morning and she's like hey babe
it's picture hanging day let's picture
hanging day and I'm exotic Canadian
holiday and I get for her a picture
hanging day it's like a celebration of
two eyes becoming one for me that's
today all my pictures find out you're
not good enough to be on the wall
anymore
thanks for playing young guns to post
her into the closet you go down in a
blaze of glory
we're still good friends we we support
each other for two reasons one we really
care about each other and two she
dabbled in witchcraft
you want to get on the wrong side of a
Ouija board like I don't believe in it
but I don't not believe in it that was
my one rules you cannot bring a Ouija
board into my apartment cuz like just
nobody's lives have been improved by a
Ouija board I don't have any friends
like man I was down and out then I found
Ouija now you see Ray Leone on a
commercial I tried everything to quit
smoking then I started communicating
with the afterlife we'll hang out all
the time we talk we talk about who were
hooking up with now it's usually a
one-sided conversation but we do get to
share custody of the dog and this is a
great story because the dog lives with
her and so after I moved out she had her
first guy since me come over and he
spent the night and guess who peed on
the rug the next day besides me guess
who else peed on the rug good times man
and then and then my my ex got me
because she's like yeah I think Molly's
just freed up as the guy was so much
bigger so it makes sense see good line
there's a good line give her credit for
that one
she won I think we're just in different
times in our life - because I'm 38 she's
very different places in your life cuz
when you're a young lady and you're in
your late 20s you do everything right
you go out you go to concerts go to
festivals when you're guiding you're my
age you go to the doctor and for the
first time you have to take it seriously
have to listen to what this guy's
telling you everything he says you're
just looking I'm like - you're a high
school basketball coach like yes sir I
will run through that wall I went to a
naturopathic doctor naturopathic is
Latin for it does not take health
insurance and
got everything looked at head to toe got
the plumbing checked out my test results
came back my doctor informed me that I'm
in danger of having low testosterone but
you here and you want to get pissed off
you just do not have the energy
it ain't theirs what if Stephanie is
afterwards my doctor sat me down he said
Marc you have to accept the fact they
are approaching the end of your sexual
peak and I was like that was my sex
school that's as good as it gets
cuz when you're kid you hear one day
you're gonna have a sexual peak and in
our heads we're thinking man I'm gonna
be in the top of a mountain it's gonna
be hot chicks everywhere
yo he pulled out a chart he pulled out a
chart he's like yeah this is where a man
has the majority of his sex and I was
like sir I brought my chart
no such mountain I didn't have a sexual
peak it was just a long Canyon and there
are no women there's just a bunch of
tissues and magazines a USB Drive
labeled tax returns that was my sexual
peak
and that's where the younger woman older
women that's a different thing because
older women what do you always hear
about older women you hear they're great
in bed and that's awesome what worries
me how'd you get that good because you
start thinking about wait nobody just
wakes up the star of Cirque de Soleil
that takes years and years it's
intimidating you hook up with an older
woman you go back to her place and it
feels like you're walking into old
Yankee Stadium for the very first time
because you're just thinking about all
the greats that have played here before
you got jerseys retired in her living
room sign above her bedroom door says
play like a champion today and you're
like and it's funny to think about how
long life is how quick life goes by
because now I've become the last single
guy every group of friends you all start
out single then one by one start getting
picked off get married you have kids
then you have that one idiot friend left
that never got it together tada
Michael Buble with a drinking problem
this is him
all my friends are married now I still
get to hang out them but it's a very
different hang like when you hang out
your married friends got one of two
options you get to have like one beer at
like 6:45 or it's the go crazy option
when she goes out of town that's when
you get a random phone call from one of
your friends like tuna behind 7-eleven
with a bag of heroin get here we got 48
hours get here right now let's figure
out how to do this but what are you
supposed to be supposed to stay single
like staying single the technology is
getting creepy you know that Google the
other day sex robots yeah
I googled sex robot when you google sex
robots your facebook ads changed
dramatically
and I'm not having sex robots for the
simple reason I'm worried that a sex
robot is gonna work a lot like a Fitbit
I guess it as you're done it's gonna
upload all your stats to Facebook I
don't want that your co-workers coming
by the next day hey Bob three minutes
new record well done I don't want a sex
robot because I'm worried that that's
the way we all go down
you know like think about it men don't
really deserve sex robots we don't treat
human women all that well how do they
were gonna react with sex robots they
were gonna clean that thing after every
use hell no it's gonna go in the closet
come out go in the closet back and forth
until the robot gets pissed off had
enough when are you gonna be having sex
with that robot and its eyes gonna turn
red and Skynet has begun that's how the
revolution starts I've never enjoyed
mixing sex with technology even when I
had the girlfriend I'd be on the road
for stand-up and she would always want
to lea do not eat eggs she'd send me
pictures of herself in very compromising
positions you know I see pictures of her
boobs and I'm like that's awesome
and then I'm like oh no now I have to
respond
he's not going in the game I've never
sent a dick pic in my life on purpose
sent one by accident Quinn's I here's
what happened I was depositing a check
on my phone I don't like walk into a
bank like hey where's the cameras you
guys so I was depositing it you know you
do it on your phone like I was in my
apartment was 9 p.m. so the pants been
off for a number of hours now and you
you laid the check on a flat surface
take a picture
flip it over take another picture hit
Send and boom 17 dollars in your account
the next day so do all those things and
right before I hit Send I see in the
corner of the picture Waldo I found him
and you know when your brain like sends
a signal to stop my brain send the
signal but my finger is like I can beat
the light and it hits said it was so
depressing y'all it was like in my mind
the check had like a hard life and it
had finally earned its first vacation
and it was trying to take a selfie on
the beach and my dick was photo blocking
even want to deal with dating apps like
I I know that's how most people meet
these days and that's fine I just look
at it and it's not that classic idea of
romance we were all talking we were kids
like a dating app is fine but you think
about how your grandparents got together
everybody to this room y'all's
grandparents all got together the same
way
grandpa and grandma they all met in a
field running towards each other Grampa
saw grandma for the first time he knew
she was the one for him grandma saw
grandpa for the first time she knew he
was the one for her you just opposed
that idea of true love what we're gonna
be telling our grandkids well grandma
said she was down to [ __ ] on bumble so I
took a shot
d under BUTT STUFF question mark the
rest is history
the real reason the real reason why I'm
not pursuing anybody right now I enjoy
being single is because I'm so happy
with this station in my life and how I
get to interact with my family I love
seeing my brother and his family my
sister and her family my mom aunts
uncles it's a great time every time we
get together the Ellis family we will
roast each other we make fun of each
other we tell stories we will bring up
the dirt on everyone we sit around we
laugh we have a great time there is only
one story in the history of Ellis
mythology that does not come out of
family gatherings that we never talk
about that is so far back in our
collective repressed memory it has never
been spoken about since the day it
happened until right now this is the one
so this is when I had my first serious
girlfriend in college so what a wait I
dated a girl in high school her name was
Magic the Gathering and we were home for
Easter weekend and just so you guys know
we're all still friends to this day
but that weekend parents loved her
everything's going great
Sunday morning rolls around Easter
Sunday and I don't know where my dad my
brother and my sister were they were off
somewhere so it's just me and my
girlfriend eating breakfast in the
kitchen my mom's there my mom says all
right kids I'm gonna go to the grocery
store be back in about an hour
grocery stores at least 20 minutes that
way 20 minutes back got to buy food it's
gonna be about an hour so at that point
I'm not thinking hey it's [ __ ] o'clock
I'm just thinking man you really can't
eat Froot Loops seven days a week
but we're alone in the kitchen wouldn't
you know it one thing leads to another
the hormones are raging were young we're
wild were in love she comes over to me
she starts kissing me she starts kissing
me on the mouth with the tongue and it's
going great
and then she starts kissing me on my
neck and that's even better then she
starts kissing down here and when she
gets below the nipple line boys you know
your job as a gentleman is to usher her
on her journey southward safely we're
not forcing anything we're just your
tour guide okay if you're Lewis and
Clark we're Sacagawea
we're just showing you the best route to
get down there and so now it's happening
now this thing this thing is happening
at the kitchen table and we're having
such a good time we don't hear the
garage door closed I didn't hear it I
was having such a good time she didn't
hear it because at the time her ears
were covered so my mom had come home and
the way you enter our kitchen it's like
let's say this is where the action is
happening you can enter our kitchen
through here or through here you can
exit through there or through there so
my mom comes in she has a bag of
groceries under each arm y'all she
handed it like such a pro my mom walks
in sees the action drops the groceries
and just keeps walking
she did it so well that I'm thinking
like is my mom the coolest wingman of
all time she was not she was she was a
mom she was very pissed off she was very
upset to the point where she couldn't
she couldn't speak to me she couldn't
even be in the same room as me for the
rest of the day and then we get the
family dinner family dinner at the same
table and it was awkward because usually
the family dinners at the Ella's
household they were known for mirth
merriment laughter could be heard from
miles not this particular evening it's
very awkward my brother and my sister
they felt something in the air my mom I
think she took two bites for dinner and
it's like I'm eating in the laundry room
I can't do this
so she takes off my brother my sister
leave my girlfriend dozens of dishes and
then she goes upstairs so now it's just
me and my dad just me and my dad and my
dad had been informed of the day's
events some kinda head takes a long sip
off his Budweiser and he says so the
kitchen huh and I was like dad I'm sorry
I know mom's upset I probably don't
never happen again
I am so horribly embarrassed so my dad
just looks at me and he says proud of
you boy
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you all very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you